it is time for hatred mail we continue
to debut new Patriot mail intros hatred
mail is when a professional voice-over
artist does interpretive readings of
hate mail that I get here is the Mexico
wall intro which we are debuting today
because Mexico is still paying for the
wall right I mean that's what he said it
all the campaign patriot man written by
Patriots who hate David Pakman because
America and because freedom
I love the trailing off at the end there
that's a really nice touch very trump
centric hatred mail today let's take a
listen to this week's hatred mail with
no further delay please if you agree
with this park man video then please
leave the United States we really don't
want you here anyway move to liberal
Europe or go back to Argentina with
Pakman it's not too expensive and it
sounds like you'll really enjoy the
people and the political climate much
more the rest of us stupid people will
stay here to continue to make this the
most exciting and uniquely successful
nation ever created on God's green earth
mega USA Trump forever so when I tell
you that it's not a good use of time to
try to convince trumpets to change their
mind and vote for somebody else in 2020
that's a perfect example ok you show
that person a global warming climate
change documentary they're not going to
have some kind of awakening you explain
to them that the way to prevent abortion
is by making contraceptives readily
available and comprehensive same-sex
education available they're not going to
all of a sudden say you know what I
think you're right I now see the light
that's why you should not waste your
time with people like that hatred and by
the way move to liberal Europe I would
love to spend more time in Europe it's
actually hard to move to Europe you may
not you may not know that I was working
for a while with my mom trying to get
polish citizenship my grandfather left
Poland before World War two and there's
a provision that if
you were escaping the Holocaust from
Poland you can actually get citizenship
and then your descendants can get it but
we weren't able to get the paperwork the
paperwork was burned up in the Holocaust
incredibly so I would love to be able to
spend more time in Europe but
unfortunately it is not the easiest
thing to do but more on my personal
legal battles on the bonus show maybe if
you want to send a middle finger salute
to the hey tree it's there's no better
way than using the coupon code hey tree
at 40 when you sign up for a membership
on our website wwlp.com coupon code hey
tree at 40 saves you 40% but you still
get 100% of the member benefits very
very exciting stuff